there's something that makes you  automatically swipe right on tinder if  they have a great smile that's like oh  that's a that's a weakness that's hard  to pass up on  if their bio makes me laugh  and isn't douchey then that's also a  great plus  i  love foosball more than anything in the  world is that a turn on or turn off well  i would have to know them i'm sure  because there's like 43 football players  but no i would love that i mean if  somebody's really good at foosball that  is a huge turn on to me okay what's like  the worst thing they could do like a lot  of jewelry if it's like too much of a  captain jack sparrow vibe if i feel like  you have more accessories than i do then  that's concerning and a bunch of near  selfies if it's all mirrors